it's great to welcome to the program
today corey doctorow who's the author of
two new books how to destroy
surveillance capitalism
also attack surface the third
installment
in the new york times best-selling
little brothers series
corey so great to have you on today it's
my pleasure thank you for having me on
so to start with we've talked about
surveillance capitalism on the program
before but as someone who's really
written a lot about this
how do you explain the concept to
someone who may not be familiar with it
well it should be noted that i i don't
agree with the
majority criticism of surveillance
capitalism yes i i think that um
the the majority criticism goes
basically google invented a mind control
rate to sell you a fidget spinner and
then robert mercer used it to make your
uncle racist
and and i think that you know this gives
google way too much credit it gives big
tech too much credit the
the history is littered with people who
claim that they could influence us with
technology
and mostly what they do is influence
their potential customers like
advertisers to give them a lot of money
but then under deliver
i think there's every indication that
that's what google and facebook and
other ad tech companies are doing which
is not to say that they aren't
spying on us like crazy they are and
it's not to say that that's not harmful
it's
super is and it's and it's not to say
that they don't distort our discourse
they do but they do so because they're
monopolists
and monopolists get to subvert the
regulatory process so they can do
dangerous things like
over surveillance and over retention of
data and then you know if there's only
one place we go to ask questions
the answer that they give us matters a
lot to what we believe but
not because they have a mind control ray
just because they become a canonical
source
so for people who have read about
surveillance capitalism often uh it's
shashana zubaf's work that that
folks may be may be familiar with so
correct me if i'm wrong and i'm glad for
you to kind of go into this it seems as
though
maybe you you believe that shashana is
correctly
identifying some of the characteristics
but
the conclusions that she comes to are
not necessarily your conclusions
yeah so i think that zuboff really does
believe
that machine learning allows us allows
tech companies to manipulate us to take
away what she calls our right to the
future tense right the right to
to be able to decide for ourselves what
we'll do in the future and i think that
um
that's not true of machine learning but
it's totally true of monopoly
right if all of your friends are
corralled on facebook then
facebook can tell you with a high degree
of accuracy that you're gonna have to
stay on facebook to talk to them
and uh you know a way to maybe visualize
the difference between our points of
view
is that she thinks that traditional uh
pro competition
remedies like breaking the companies up
or opening them up to interoperability
or anything else that we might do to
reduce their power will just produce
like
hundreds of pipsqueaks each of them with
their own mind control ray and we won't
even be able to keep track of them and
how they're using them
so imagine that there was a comet headed
towards earth and you had someone who
said no no
we can't try and break the comet up if
we do it'll turn into a million meteors
and they'll just smash every city on
earth
we have to we have to steer the comet
and that's what she thinks right she
thinks we need to
tame the companies by telling them what
they can and can't do
putting them under tighter control and
so on and i just don't think you can put
them under control for so long as they
have monopolies
because they have so much excess money
from being monopolists
and they're so concentrated that they
can agree on how to spend that money
that they can end up steering their own
course you know people look at that
picture of the tech leaders with donald
trump in 2016 at the top of trump tower
on that table meeting with them and they
go like
how can tim cook and all these other
self-described bastions of liberalism
meet with donald trump and that's a fair
question but a better one is
how is it that everyone who runs tech
fits around a single table
that that should be even more alarming
and so when you talk about
the how the the monopoly aspect
is a big piece of why the status quo
is as it is let's talk through what it
would look like if that if that weren't
the case because i could imagine that
if instead of facebook google amazon you
know pick pick
pick the five and say instead there's
ten in each
instead of each of the five i could
imagine well
if everybody is more spread out rather
than on one platform
it's harder to be as accurately
predictive about how people are going to
be
behaving online because you've only got
a fraction of the data rather than a
huge portion of it at the same time
there's the money argument which is
if you have 50 players instead of five
no one of them is going to be so well
funded that maybe they can
so how much of it is is the the
financial piece
how much of it is the sort of network
effect of everybody being on on
a few platforms well let's talk about
network effects because
um historically network effects for tech
were not as durable
as they are in other areas like say
railroads right network effects and
railroads are super powerful because
once you've got the rails
everyone's got to use them and no one
wants to build a second set of rails
next to your rails
right but if you're say ibm and you have
this giant printer division called
lexmark
and you have the network effects of of
having this huge customer base
uh and you then decide to extract high
rents for
your toner right the carbon that you put
into them and use a security chip to
make sure no one puts their own carbon
in it carbon is obviously a very
abundant element we're struggling to
deal with an overabundance of carbon
not hard to get all the carbon you need
so along comes a little taiwanese
company called static controls and they
use the network effect like
judo because they say hey look ibm has
created this huge market of people who
bought subsidized printers
we can sell them cheap toner they clone
ibm's chip right they make an
interoperable chip
and now they own lexmark they bought
lexmark from ibm
or if you're apple and you're being out
competed by microsoft and the enterprise
because microsoft deliberately breaks
compatibility between microsoft office
for the mac and microsoft office for
windows
you can just say well to heck with
microsoft we're just going to reverse
engineer how microsoft office works and
release the iworksuite pages and numbers
and keynote
so that mac users can just interoperate
with windows users so
what i think is that when people have
problems
with the way that tech works uh and
and those problems can be the result of
tech trying to do something harmful to
them like manipulate them
or it can just be the result of tech not
considering their uses right um
you know the the technology that we've
all encountered that assumes that you've
always got a reliable internet
connection
has proved a lot less reliable than we
hoped it would now that we're all stuck
at home and
sharing our internet with all of our
neighbors all day long
you get to modify it or you get to find
someone to modify or someone identifies
you as a market and modifies that tech
so that it suits your needs and not the
needs of the shareholders of the people
who made it in the first place
and that in that world the equilibrium
we get is companies competing to see
how happy they can make you not
companies competing to see
how tightly they can control your
actions in the future so that you're
stuck with them
i i want to continue down this path but
one
sort of small tangential issue i'm
curious to get your thoughts about is
i was recently speaking to someone in
the tech space who said you know with a
lot of the you pick pick
some niche area where there's like one
one big player
um if you were to all of a sudden get 10
players in that same space
in all likelihood they'd all be using
amazon web services and so jeff bezos
basically could still flip one switch
and shut all ten of them down
that that's a very practical concern but
it's a real one isn't it
it certainly is and that's why you know
traditional anti-monopoly remedies
um are include something called
structural separation which was in the
congressional report that was released
this week as well
and structural separation starts with
things like railroads being banned from
owning coal companies or freight
companies where they own
the people that they haul freight for or
they own
businesses that compete with the people
that they haul freight for
and you could imagine a structural
separation regime for amazon where they
say you can be a platform
or you can use the platform but you
can't compete with the users of the
platform if you own the platform
that's like the casino boss coming down
and gambling at the table opposite you
and the croupier knows that if the
casino boss loses
that koopie loses their job too right we
want we want a level playing field there
um and i and i want to stress that
there's like a little nuance here
because
although i think the monopolies that
tech has created
are the same mediocre sociopathic
bullying tactics that
we saw with coal and that we saw with
electricity that we see today with like
beer
and with logistics and and so many other
industries that have become super
concentrated pro wrestling is down to
one league
right uh that there is one way in which
tech is very different and it is this
compatibility idea
that that making a pro wrestling league
that can interact with other pro
wrestling leagues seamlessly is hard
making a version of office for the mac
that can read and write office for
windows
turned out to be pretty straightforward
and the history of technology is filled
with these companies that had dominance
like amazon
and saw that dominance taken away from
them because of inter-operators because
of competitive compatibility
making new things that plug into old
things even though the people who made
those old things
don't want you to and you're eating
their lunch by doing so
to pick one of the things you you
mentioned to dig into a little deeper
um our data the the data about us about
our activities
and big tech having that data using the
data
to market to us or through tracking
pixels allowing
third parties to target us in in very
specific ways
there's a panoply of ideas about
how and why this is bad can you focus in
on again
with your background in writing science
fiction as well and having no shortage
of connection to dystopian futures and
near futures and so on
what are the real concerns there about
big tech having our data which ones
maybe are overblown in your mind
so i i want to um dig into this but it
is like a technical and complicated
issue so i'm just going to give you like
a top line here
yeah um when we release data or when we
uh harvest data and hold it and think
about the risk of it being released
non-consensually like it leaking or
being hacked from us or what have you
we try to anticipate the risks from that
data being released and when we give
data to companies we try to anticipate
those risks what could they do
with x and y and z x and y and z on
their own aren't a big deal so the nhs
and the uk where i used to live
did a controlled data release of
prescribing data longitudinal
prescribing data which is a super useful
thing to have
so that you know they they gave each
patient a random identifier
and then they said which doctor
prescribed which meds to that person on
what day which hospital
and we could see over there that through
that data set you could see you know
like is there a risk if they if your
doctor puts you on statins that you'll
then have to go on tricyclic
antidepressants or something stuff like
that that is
hard to see in individual cases or in
studies but the data might reveal
so that felt like a safe bet you know if
you asked me to review that data release
i would have said i can't see any real
risk
in this release but then a a
taxi company had a breach and that taxi
company was widely used by patients who
went to hospitals for prescriptions
and so now you can see the person who
went from david pakman's house
to this hospital to get these tricyclic
antidepressants
or uh hormones that are given to people
who are undergoing gender transition
or some other very sensitive prescribing
data that correlates exactly with david
going back and forth to the hospital
so in order to understand the risks of a
data harvesting
a data release or giving your data to
someone
you have to be able to anticipate all
the other data that might be collected
and released in the future
that's a very hard thing to be able to
understand
and so the the risk is effectively
infinite
right that it's it's it is a an
unquantifiable risk
that happens when we gather and create
large data sets and the lesson of
history
is that if you collect data it will
probably breach and if you retain it
long enough it will absolutely breach
i mean the thing i always tell firms
when they ask me about this is
if the nsa couldn't stop snowden from
leaking
their documents right what makes you
think that you're gonna be able to stop
someone from leaking
your documents when you think about
everything under
consumer marketing where you have a
debate
as to you know it's creepy
how targeted ads are to me and the other
side being
aren't you better off if you're going to
see ads either way wouldn't you rather
than be more relevant is that not even
the right question to be asking when it
comes to the data stuff
well thankfully we've got a really easy
way to answer that which is uh
comes from competitive compatibility
it's called ad blocking
right if people so the ad blocking is
used most aggressively
by users who encounter the most
aggressive behavioral advertising that
is to say the most customized
advertising that is the
the greatest trigger of adblock one in
four web users uses adblock
uh doc searles calls it the largest
consumer boycott in history
uh that number is going up browsers are
integrating it by default
and so if your question is like do
people not mind personalized advertising
the answer is pretty clearly
no people don't like personalized
advertising they find it creepy
uh what's more you know speaking of
someone who owns a web publishing
business
uh um behavioral advertising doesn't
deliver very good value to publishers so
first is that right
oh yeah well so that the ad tech
companies take a tax of up to 50
on every dollar that behavioral
advertising brings in
depending on what kind of vertical you
publish in a quarter or half or even
more of your users might not see those
behavioral ads because they have tracker
blockers and then
finally we have an alternative right so
we we
the premise of behavioral advertising is
that the best way to predict whether an
ad will work
is to analyze the person you're showing
the ad to
but there's another predictor another
way to predict it which is to analyze
the thing that they're looking at and
that's called a contextual ad
and contextual ads have no privacy
dimension
right all you do is you say well what's
this article about that article
is highly likely to be a thing that the
person who's reading the article is
about so let's see if there are any ads
in inventory
that are about the same thing as the
article and put the ad alongside the
article and there's a dutch national
broadcaster that did this
they not only saw uh eighty percent
year on year growth so i was thinking 62
percent the first month and 79
the second month of it but the growth
that they saw
in in um uh click through was
also increased by the fact that they
didn't pay half the money to an ad tech
company that sat in the middle
so i i think that um we we have
alternatives for advertising
advertising's always been really
important to the free press i mean the
historic story of the of the small town
newspaper has always been
that people want to see sports scores
and the local washing machine company
wants to sell white goods
and so they uh the newspaper family
takes the ads for the washing machines
and shows them to people who want to see
sports scores
and out of a sense of civic duty spend
pays someone to go sit in city hall and
take notes on the school board meetings
and and publishes that as the
as the kind of uh the the uh vegetables
that go along with the dessert of the
sports scores
and and you know advertising has always
been key to how we get that kind of
civic reporting
uh i am a canadian who lived in the uk
for a long time now i live in the us i
think public media has an enormous role
to play here
but so does ads and those ads do not
have to be surveillant to be effective
and in fact from the perspective of a
publisher it's better if they aren't
so let me let me re kind of rephrase
what you're saying because i think this
is interesting so
there's the idea that's often just
assumed
that the more tailored the ad is to the
person
based on what tv shows do they like how
much time do they spend online what can
you guess about their income based on
activity
that not only is there a creepy factor
but that the ads by being very tailored
in total net net net will be more
profitable
even accounting for what you're spending
to have the ad so highly targeted
the counter to this would be if you
simply say hey you know what
without knowing anything about
individuals if you put ads
for solar panels on articles about
electric vehicles
you're going to get a pretty good result
or better than average result
you're not spending money on the hyper
targeting
and your net revenue will be better
and yeah and to get back to this idea of
mind control raise you know the source
of the first story you told
are the companies that sell ad tech
right and and so they're not a great
source
for this stuff i mean one of the
problems i find with uh with the
surveillance capitalism story
is it starts from a bunch of really true
facts like tech lies
all the time facebook claimed that they
wouldn't merge the instagram and
whatsapp back ends with its own backend
when they caught them
they lied and they did it google told us
that it's cars that did street view
wouldn't uh gather data from our wi-fi
networks they lied and they did it and
so these people are like look at these
liars and tech
the only time they're telling the truth
is when they're trying to sell their
products to advertisers
and i think that that is a the wrong
place to assume
that you're getting the truth i think
that the pitch from the sales force
is the uh probably the least truthful
thing that a company produces
you know sight unseen that as a as a
prediction
thing last thing i want to ask about
andrew yang when he ran
for the democratic primary talked about
your data has value you should be able
to either
choose to sell your data get some some
money for that or whatever the case may
be
two-part question is that feasible
and number two would that really solve
anything
i don't think that solves a a a darn
thing um
so when you actually look at the value
that these companies extract from your
data it's not a very
large sum of money so uh it's not like
we'd be cleaning up from it
but the idea that you own your data is a
really complicated idea
you know so so take the fact that your
mother is your mother
who owns that fact who gets to sell it
to facebook is it you or your mom
does your dad get to sell that to
facebook what if you want to sell not
just the fact that your
mom is your mother to facebook but you
want to
um trade the information that your mom
was abusive
to facebook and your mom says no i don't
want that data sold to facebook
that's not your data that's my data or
how about if your boss was abusive does
he own that fact or do you own that fact
now we have a lot of ways of talking
about valuable things without putting
price tags on them in fact the most
valuable things in the world
are never priced human beings right if
you describe
kidnapping as theft of child you are a
monster
because the problem with kidnapping is
not the monetary value you have lost
when your child was kidnapped
it is the price to the human being
in a wildly unequal monopolized world
putting price tags on data
just means that people who already lack
market power the poorest among us who
cannot afford
access to for pay services will be uh
pressurized to sell their data they'll
be pressurized to sell it at very low
prices
um and we'll just magnify inequality
right we already have a situation
where the lies are free and the truth is
paywalled if we then say privacy is a
luxury good that's only available to the
wealthy
we magnify the inequalities that created
that situation
in other words those who don't need the
money from their data
are more likely not to sell it and it it
and it furthers
that gap by that very virtually
absolutely
yeah and you know and if you think that
like there won't be someone who says
oh no i don't need your data uh what i
will do is i'll just set up a free
service where you don't have to trade
your data
um but where you're not allowed to say
nasty things about donald trump
for example or about rich people or
about uh
tax breaks um you know that that is that
is also a remedy that is likely to
emerge from it
there are things that we just tell
people they're not allowed to do
right we don't let people sell their
organs uh we don't let companies
create click-through agreements that say
by being dumb enough to be my customer
you agree i can have your kidneys
so you know if we're gonna say that uh
there
are systemic risks from data releases
risk to third parties
risks that are not risk to you but risk
to the people around you
when you when you release data then we
should have rules
that are not grounded in property rights
that are so blended and incoherent that
we could never have a functional market
for them
instead we should have rules grounded in
principle that that try to find
equilibriums that are good for the
public interest we may get those rules
wrong we may have to revisit them
but the idea that markets will find that
equilibrium is just wrong on its face
we've been speaking with corey doctorow
who is the author of two new books how
to destroy surveillance capitalism also
attack surface
the third installment in the new york
times best-selling
little brothers series corey i so
appreciate your time today
thank you very much and i'll mention
that the novel is really about techies
wrestling with these questions
in a high-tech high-stakes techno
thriller so that if if this kind of
thing interests you
but non-fiction is in your bag and you
want a standalone uh
uh techno thriller instead uh that's
where you can start
awesome